il ya plein de secrets sur les bogdanoff
mode s qui ces briques avait un
troisième frère non non il n'y a pas de
troisième frère ils ont plein de frère
et soeur ils ont un autre frère ils ont
trois autres soeurs mais qui sont nés
plus de dix ans après leur naissance a
eu il ya que deux jumeaux des jumeaux
les frères bogdanoff alors est-ce qu'ils
ont modifié leur identité ou ce qui
s'appelle plus gros alors grichka pour
de vrai son vrai prénom c'est grégoire
de danse on est content civile mais en
réalité c'est bien au stade cenco
bogdanov ça c'est leur vrai nom le nom
de leur père mais ce qu'ils ont à
modifier c'est pas leur identité c'est
d'où ils viennent c'est à dire que plein
de fois il se présentait comme le fils
d'un grand prince russe ce sens c'est un
prince blanc voilà non en réalité ce
qu'il faut bien savoir pour comprendre
les bogdanoff c'est leur grand mère leur
grand mère elle vient en effet
d'autriche hongrie c'était une très très
très très grande noblesse est là elle a
connu par ses grands parents si si et
puis en plus intrusif une impératrice
bien sûr un sens ils sont violés
bogdanov ça c'était leur grand mère et
donc du coup ça nous ramène à une très
très grande noblesse il trouve que cette
femme elle va complètement tombé raide
dingue amoureuse de roland ice c'est à
dire un grand ténor noirs américains
dans les années 20 qui arrive et elle va
avoir une passion pour lui elle va
tomber enceinte à ce moment là elle est
mariée elle a quatre enfants et son mari
lui dit non mais on met ton enfant dans
une clinique en suisse mais reste avec
nous et non elle part parce qu'elle veut
créer une nouvelle race d'hommes
vraiment et elle veut ce petit garçon
les persuader que c'est un petit garçon
elle en est persuadé et c'est une petite
fille et elle s'installe donc dans le
gers et avec sa petite fille avait bal
va pas du tout s'en occuper ça va être
une catastrophe
et quand les bogdanoff vont naître grâce
à cette femme des années plus tard grâce
à youri ce type qui absolument pas un
prince russe ben là elle va voler les
bogdanoff et veut vraiment volé les
bogdanoff et elle va en faire ces petits
princes de nous il ya mini bonbons par
mme l'expand igor qui a d'ailleurs pris
la parole après la cérémonie regardez
[Applaudissements]
leurs histoires leurs familles étaient
très très belles choses et au fond
c'était très émouvant parce que
justement c'était là c'était la suite de
l'histoire et à trop tôt mais très bel
ensemble alors il ya plein de gens aussi
qu'on dit que les bogdanoff est atteint
d'une maladie génétique est ce que c'est
vrai ce qu ils ont laissé courir la
rumeur du fait qu'ils auraient eu
l'acromégalie et l'acromégalie ça fait
pousser les membres et notamment les
mains et les pieds non il n'avait pas du
tout et l'acromégalie eu ce qu'il
voulait c'est que on parle d'eux le plus
possible mais vous savez très bien fait
de la chirurgie donc c'est quoi c'est dû
c'est comme a dit luc ferry c'est du
botox première opération avant temps x
le menton parce qu'il trouvait que leur
père avait un menton trop fuyants donc
ils vont se faire déjà donc en 78 ils
ont mis en vente opération un premier
petit menton mais raisonnable si vous
regardez les ils ont rajouté un déjà une
prothèse et puis havrais en 2005 ça
voilà ça c'est déjà une prothèse mais en
2005 qu'ils arrivent
qu'ils
sont beaux comme ça longtemps hors télé
et là d'un seul coup là bas ils arrivent
sur toutes les télés et tout le monde
leur dis mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
menton dirait toutankhamon voilà il ya
une des blagues de batterie très connus
nation tu es beaucoup avec sa série sur
les plateaux parce que enfin à chaque
fois qu'on posait la question c'est
vraiment très très compliqué voulait
jamais répondre et ça se voyait quand
même quelque part parce que vous qui les
avez reçues qui dont vous étiez très
très remarqué
qu'on peut déjà pas naturel et ensuite
on pouvait remarquer aussi on le voit
sur les photos des bulbes à y vas tu es
petit straps juste là qui permet de
tenir parce que je sais que moi igor on
en avait beaucoup parlé ensemble ça lui
arrive et ce sans faire lui-même
carrément des injections de quoi
c'est pour ça que je sois salle est un
petit peu trop loin et donc du coup ça
des fois c'était pas très uniforme quoi
c'est un des secrets vous qui connaissez
très bien mode mode libre et donc il se
soignait jamie alors ils n'avaient pas
de carte vitale tant qu'ils n'avaient
pas de carte vitale il était vraiment
persuadés qu'ils étaient en superforme
s'y sont déjà tombés malades gravement
ou avoir aidé oui aux oreilles des
maladies n'ont rien de rien de jamais
n'ont rien de notable c'est vrai qu'ils
gore notamment était vraiment pendant
longtemps une force de la nature qu'ils
aient des escalades avec raphaël
enthoven notamment et tous les deux tout
bien savoir en boîte de nuit parce qu'on
a dit que c'était des oiseaux de nuit ah
oui mais quand ils ont leurs verres
jamais ils touchent jamais boire ça les
dégoûte jala des graines schyman il doit
quoi dans les vers du dos à la dégoûte
c'est les dégoûter huawei et donc ils
sont jamais faits soit n'a jamais été
voir un médecin de leur vie si elle aura
un pari de culte il est vrai que c'est
vrai qu il était persuadé qu'on en est
en ce1 en se nourrissant sainement en
faisant du sport eh bien on reste en
bonne santé il était vraiment persuadé
que là il était immunisé contre le coc
vide et qui risque et qu'ils ont donc
ils ont rien fait comment ah non ça je
pense qu'ils ont rien fait ils ont rien
fait donc ils ont ce n'est pas à partir
du tout soit il se dit oh ça va passer
alors on fait comment quand j'ai écrit
livre donc il est sorti en 2019 raphaël
enthoven avait vraiment été très longs
mois
sur leur santé en disant qu' il était
souvent en colère et est inquiet parce
que maintenant ils commencent à vieillir
et notamment igor commence à voir des
projets 72 ans et que et qui soignait
pas et que à force de croire qu'ils
étaient immortalise allait mourir
beaucoup plus vite que prévu et s'est il
donc le coc vide bien sûr pas de vaccin
pas de carte vitale jamais de médecins
ils ont eu ce qu'ils ont appelé un
médecin pour savoir qu'ils avaient
commis ou pas du tout qu'il fait
je crois que ses médecins rien de tout
ça plus jamais le médecin je crois que
jamais donc ici si l'on écouté en tout
cas aucun de leurs proches qui a qui ont
vraiment comme vous le disiez a essayé
d'insister parce que c'est la copine
de grichka je crois qu'il l'emmenait à
l'hôpital si j'ai bien compris c'est
passé comme ça elle l'a vu que ça
n'allait pas et c'est elle qui a pris la
décision de l'emmener pour l'hôpital
mais selon lui il aurait qualifié qui a
convaincu igor ensuite c'est que les
chaque étudiant de le rejoindre c'est
comme ce qu'ils voulaient pas du tout ce
qui est fou c'est qu'il ya des images
ils ont répondu à une interview de
france bleu le 6 décembre où ils sont en
tout cas maintenant la radio filmée il
son horizon l'air en bonne forme et ils
sont rentrés le 15 décembre je crois à
l'hôpital donc c'est vrai que
malheureusement dans cette maladie ça
peut descendre vite et voilà donc
partant dix sont pas soignés ça a été
assez rapide quand même pour vous dire
qu avez vous pensé par dont on vous dire
à quel point il pensait vraiment pas
mourir je sais qu'ils s'amusaient lors
de leurs opérations à se syndiquer l'un
et l'autre les taux d'oxygénation qu'ils
adorent wazi s'amuser en disant qu'ils
arrivaient les fans oui passer leur
temps au téléphone mais ça de façon dans
la vie courante c'était comme ça hein
quoi ils disaient ouais ils se disaient
oui on jamais vu le danger il se soumet
pas du tout je crois même que ça faisait
rire quoi fin mais ça n'aide pas du tout
ça n'aura pas du tout fait peur c'est
dans ton amant leur faisait vraiment
peur en tout cas la vieillesse est en
fait si on peut expliquer vraiment la
chirurgie elle et s'explique très
facilement c'est parce qu'ils voulaient
absolument ne pas ressembler à des
personnes âgées le sens il ne voulait
pas vieillir donc il voulait être autres
leur grand-mère son sac j'insiste sur la
grand mère voulait qu'il soit
exceptionnel et ils ont voulu être
exceptionnel jusqu'au bout quitte à
ressembler alors il ya des gens qui
disent vraiment ben voilà il était
devenu est ce que c'est vraiment être
beau bon chacun jugera c est vraiment
exceptionnel en personne ne leur
ressemblait en tout cas moi moi ce que
est collé c'était c'était des
personnages je vous dis 95 % de
notoriété les bogdanoff il faut dire
qu'en france tout le monde connaissait
les bagdadis 95 % de notoriété c'est
très rare je voulais un cc c'est
incroyable c'est lé président de la
république c c'était un personnage qui
était un des personnages les personnes
les plus connus en france est ce que
c'est vrai est ce que vous le savez
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils seraient qui
dissimulait une immense fortune ah non
alors la banque fortis est surprenant
c'est vrai qu'elle les eût ci pourront
vous le dire ce qu'est ce qui est génial
avec eux c'est qu'ils ont un fatalisme
incroyable c'est vrai qu'avec temps x
ils ont gagné de l'argent mais ils ont
tout dilapidé ils ont eu des porsche ils
ont eu les lits qu ils ont vécu comme
tout le monde et puis d'un seul coup il
est plus rien les huissiers venait
piquer tous les meubles vous avez vu
chez eux un peu médiévale piquer tous
les modèles tous les maux mais il avait
plus rien et pour il y avait aucun
problème ils organisaient des soirées
chez eux bof la lumière s'arrêter parce
que il n'avait pas payé des problèmes on
a allumé des petites bougies c'était
charmant et voilà on y mettez une bougie
sur le menton
mais en fait vous êtes le troisième
temps castaldi non mais c'est vrai si
vous avez
serré cool et on les aime et il adorait
qu'on rigole avait très franchement bien
l'auto dérision c'est incroyable que
génial c'est que il acceptait toutes les
émissions de télé c'est sa radio cet
orient ça faisait faire tant cibler
leurs de trucs il faisait tout bas il ya
une question qui est posée est ce que
quelqu'un peut me répondre à cette
question là est-ce que celui qui a
survécu a connu le nom en fait igor ne
savais pas que cliff cas voilà c'est ça
c'est le réservoir ils savaient pas ils
ne savaient pas il est déjà dans le coma
voilà c'est ça donc il n'a jamais su et
il a rejoint ses jours après ces cd oui
gilles sur l'argent je voulais revenir
sur l'argent c'est vrai qu'ils avaient
touché beaucoup de droits d'auteur à un
moment ils vendaient très bien et puis
après leur thèse avait été contestée et
se sont battus pendant des années pour
faire valider leurs thèses et ça leur a
coûté énormément d'argent en avant
guingamp nuissier parce que ils ont mis
des années à ce que notamment le cnrs
qui les chargeait ne les impacts plus et
donc une partie de leur fortune est
parti là dedans il avait d'ailleurs un
château dans le gers qui ne pouvaient
pas restauré il ne pouvait plus l'argent
c'est un saint ce sujet que j'aime bien
commencer un petit peu donc du coup ça
que je leur avais beaucoup posé de
questions
compliquées et donc du coup c'était
quelque chose est très complexe l'argent
donc du coup je sais que c'était
vraiment des sujets qu'il fallait pas
trop trop aborder et j'avais posté des
questions notamment au niveau des
salaires et c'est vrai que c'était
quelque chose de très complexe qu'on
sait pas trop aux plus avancés pas trop
et je sais qu'au niveau de l'argent
c'était surtout les livres il avait un
avaloir à peu près de 180 mille euros
parmi les derniers livres donc c'était
pour les de 1,9 à les diviser par deux
les dernières choses à dire sur l'argent
cyril c'est que moi j'ai été regardé les
statuts je suis tombé sur quelque chose
hier en fait il avait créé une société
cette société s'était temps x elle était
estimée à 6 millions d'euros non donc
qui sont morts millionnaire tous les
deux ils avaient évalué chacun 3
millions d'euros leur part sur chaque
parent de société donc tous les deux
avaient créé une société qui s'appelait
temps lille c'était il ya un an et donc
du coup ils sont morts millionnaire bah
écoute alors est ce que les frères
bogdanoff vont être montés ensemble
ils vont être dans le gers faut vraiment
voir que c'est très important le gers
peureux surtout pour pour igor cadorette
sur le tracteur cadoret vraiment est la
campagne c'est au nom parce que c'est
pas du tout l'image qu'on en a deux mais
ils ont vraiment un côté terroir très
très important dans votre émission ils
ont souvent imité l'accès du
gicat passer l'eau jean on en sait trop
ce que c'est vrai qu'ils étaient
consultés par les plus grands politiques
en secret et en plus grand homme
politique en réalité ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils étaient
vraiment très ami avec les politiques et
ce à tous les deux et notamment son pays
pourquoi ils ont eu leur dernière
émission en 2008 par sarkozy c'est pas
moi qui ai dit c'est patrick de carolis
notamment se traduire par une demande
officielle direct et qui est ce qui a
produit l'émission c'est laurent juppé
le fils d'alain juppé laurent juppé
c'est quelqu'un qui produit des super
super super émission late show
tenir et mais il était là et qui est
secret de la muse est elle de la musique
c'est dj mosey qui est le fils de
sarkozy donc oui c'est vraiment un vrai
lien mais sans panique vous avez cité
luc ferry mais il ya eu plein d'autres
gens avant plein de gens de la chiraquie
qu'on a complètement oublié des gens
comme quoi les gens comme ça pourquoi il
pose est pourquoi il portait toujours
déchets les chaussures des chaussures
bizarre ouais mais plus les chaussures
des bogdanoff monde par les blessures
dues à leur voix ils savent et ça c'est
quoi ça pourquoi cdu alors j'avais quoi
il avait
pour moi pour moi sincèrement ça fait
partie du costume 1 et le but c'est de
toute manière dans la rue qu'on les
reconnaisse c'est très important alors
les reconnaîtrez pas besoin des beurs et
non mes mains mes manches mans il aura
alors obtient mômes à moi petit moka
street a bien s'en passer aussi bien je
vous promets que nan parce que je vous
donne une mini anecdote est ce que c'est
ce qui m'a donné envie d'écrire le
bouquin j'étais au monoprix en fait d'un
seul coup j'ai vu des gamins qui se
penchait qui rigolaient comme des
baleines en disant mais regarde ça des
extraterrestres eux ils savaient pas du
tout qu'ils étaient les bogdanoff et en
fait c'est parce que il avait ses
chaussures qui était incroyable il
n'avait pas des routes a vu les
chaussures télé chaussures et voilà le
but c'était aux gars également de se
grandir de la même manière que ben leurs
cheveux alors postiches qui était aussi
pour pour se grandir et ce qui habitait
toujours ensemble non ils ont habité
très longtemps ensemble
mais mais quand même au bout d'un moment
notamment quand igor s'est marié avec
avec sa vraie première femme ce qu'il
avait déjà eu un enfant avant ils ont
arrêté des d'habiter ensemble et amélie
de bourbon-parme pour témoigner que
grichka été très souvent là je pense que
c'était beaucoup mais mais il dormait
pas là vous avez filmé la maison je
crois exactement bien sûr mon chéri
drôle bien sûr pas merci est-ce qui est
ce que les bogdanoff il avait des dons
de télépathie
en tout cas moi je les ai vus parce que
je les ai invités sur le plateau et il
m'avait fait une démonstration par a
plus b l'un était dans une pièce selon
été l'hôte était dans l'autre pièce et
donc du coup par l'intermédiaire d'un
mot battu l'iphone à l'eau non ça
interne et d'un bon mais non mais on
avait déjà vu plusieurs fois des choses
assez incroyables comme ça il arrivait à
se transmettre des messages soit je
voudrais rajouter une chose quand même
que j'ai vu à la cérémonie tout à
l'heure c'est qu'il ya un scientifique
qui est venu et qui a expliqué la
tristesse qu'avait vécu igor et grichka
concernant le fait qu'ils n'étaient
jamais pris au sérieux mais ça c'est
quelque chose qui est sympa c'est pour
sa cité alors ça c'est passé tout à
l'heure pendant racontez nous parce que
pour étaient dans leurs rangs julien
n'était pas loin et même lionel stan qui
était à côté
pas faire tout le monde mais est on est
en train de discuter d'écouter tout ça
et d'un coup et un physicien qui est
arrivé que commença à parler d'igor et
grichka et c'est vrai qu'il a commencé
le ton assez fortement je me suis dit
tiens ça commence à assez fort il
expliqué en gros par a + blé qu'on les
avait beaucoup consulté beaucoup moqué
d'eux et ce qui est assez intéressant
c'est que pendant les émissions de télé
quand on leur posait des questions par
rapport à ça à chaque fois vous
regarderez ils disaient oui ou non mais
on s'en fiche de ne pas être ça nous a
blessés et ça les a beaucoup c'est ce
qu'il a expliqué et la ville une phrase
très très jolie où il a dit voilà
maintenant vous êtes parti vous
inquiétez pas c'était pas grave tout ça
vous êtes quand même de très bons
scientifiques c'était très très joli ce
qu'il a dit mais on sentait quand même
une certaine on sentait que ça il était
très énervé ce monsieur c'est vrai ça
leur a fait beaucoup de mal je pense
avoir fait de la peine tout bascule je
n'étais pas vraiment vous au sérieux
ouais donc c'est ce qu'il a dit ce
physicien table et a parlé tout à
l'heure c'est ça leur fait de la peine
ils n'ont jamais dit en fait un risque
en le revivant série qu'on n'allait
toujours l'impression que pouvaient
déconner avec eux ça mais ça les blessés
qu'on laisse aller certains
scientifiques et bien sûr les les vannes
et c'est sain c'est allé beaucoup plus
loin que ça quand ils sont décédés vous
savez ce qui était en toc tout c'est
vraiment ton la ville de menton donc
même tout le monde les prenait quand
même à la rigolade mais c'était quand
même des gens très intelligents qui
savent c'était quand même deux
scientifiques
je dirais pas ça donc c'est des
vulgarisateurs scientifiques ils ont eu
deux thèses ils ont eu beaucoup de mal à
passer ils ont fait plus de dix ans igor
a dû passer la sienne deux fois parce
que la première était trop mauvaise et
donc en fait ils sont certainement des
fulgurances et sayad et certains
scientifiques dans leurs amis qu'ils
trouvent en effet qu'il ya des
fulgurances des trucs intéressants dans
ce qu'ils portent mais c'est pas des
vrais scientifiques dans le sens où ils
n'ont pas la base mathématique pour
justement porté tous les trucs très
complexes qu'ils essaient d'être ce
qu'ils ont failli parce que c'est vrai
qu'ils ont failli mourir à l'âge de 10
ans alors il ya en effet une scène qui
est très belle ou igor a failli mourir
en fait dans le château de la grand mère
il ya eu un grand feu mais y est dedans
là le foyer de la cheminée il ya eu une
explosion est en fait d'un seul coup
igor a commencé à être pris par les
flammes et grichka la poussée en fait
c'est grichka qui a été brûlé et en fait
tout le monde me dit que c'est pour ça
qu'on n'a jamais vus grichka quasiment
maillot de bain parce que il a vraiment
été brûlée et est franchement je serais
là sauver son frère physiquement il a
donc vraiment sauver son frère l'autre
élément et ça ça explique aussi pourquoi
aujourd'hui ils étaient six ans déjà
mais alors il disputait tout le temps
mais comme des gamins comme des enfants
le subissent un honneur mais mais en
fait pour de vrai pour les trucs groupe
indique ce plan sont jamais non jamais
je pense vraiment qu'il y avait une
force incroyable et l'autre qu'aussi
donc ils sont sauvés dans l'eau et ils
ont été un tout petit peu séparés un
moment je vous ai dit que leur grand
mère les a vraiment volé donc un moment
la mère a voulu les récupérer donc ils
ont été séparés et là je pense que ça a
été un traumatisme total pour eux qui
explique aujourd'hui pourquoi après bill
était si fusionnelle donc il était tout
s'il pouvait pas bien ce ne pouvait pas
vivre l'un sans l'autre sa chance et
c'est quand même incroyable qu'ils
attrapent échos vide en même temps c'est
fou les histoires elle une histoire six
jours et non mais si ça ici c'est
incroyable ce destin pourrait penser que
l'on appelait l'autre quand même en lui
disant qu'il était parti non mais je
vous jure c'est assez incroyable un peu
magique enfin c'est magic c'est triste
mais fin de vie romanesque mais magique
c'est vrai ça très romanesque alors
alors regardez il ya plein de il ya
beaucoup d'anonymes aussi qui ont rendu
hommage à igor et grichka regardées
je les ai eus beaucoup parce que j'étais
formidable mois gérer de tous les temps
x je les regardais kg un thriller dff a
été un choc pour nous j'ai beaucoup de
peine parce que franchement c'était des
gens merveilleux
qui était proche des gens et que surtout
qui nous ont fait rêver avec temps is
tellement gentille bienveillant dans le
mental et elle était est intenable et
immoral quand j'étais petit c'était un
peu la magie
c'était c'était du super héros c'était
voilà des
super héros c'est julien oui ça parce
que ce qui m'aurait fait plaisir ce qui
nous aurait fait plaisir c'est de revoir
si c'est possible quand ils font les
l'accent gersois alors h et passion là
ça j'adore ça on va voir mais siège
façon très ému je suis installé sur wii
bien sûr moi j'étais au bord des larmes
tout à l'heure jordan on était là-bas
c'était très très dur quand on les a
bien connu voilà très dur et surtout
qu'ils partent ensemble à six jours
c'est incroyable et votre reportage là
parlent des gens qui étaient voilà côté
de la madeleine on a quand même assisté
à des scènes hallucinantes tout à
l'heure dans la madeleine je pas si tu
as vu julien mais envoyer des gens donc
inconnu qui passait la barre hier pour
aller toucher le cercueil ils sont fait
attraper par la sécurité au moins je
crois que dizaine qui sont passés par
les côtés et à la fin la sécurité
savaient tout de la tête tellement les
gens je vis à vis comme une attraction
vers les deux cercueils c'était un
simple jeu c'est pas les gens voulaient
être la touche et il y avait quelque
chose de très particulier nate mosphere
très très lourde est assez mais c'est
quoi votre dernier souvenir avec eux
c'est quoi ces cantines sont nuls il y
avait tout le temps moi c est
franchement c'est quand on a fait le jeu
te tiens tu me tiens par la barbichette
cette fois ci rien que qui pouvait le
faire et
moi est vraiment je les aime et je
dirige l'édile à la fois je ne parlerai
jamais des bogdanoff au passé parce que
monsieur ils seront toujours là on les
aime vraiment c était et je vous dis il
ya plus d'invités peu de gens que j'ai
eues dans l'émission qui venait très
souvent qu'ils vont me manquer je pense
vraiment que les bogdanoff vont nous
manquer énormément dans la vie et aussi
à ici sur cette photo a franchement pas
la roue les aime la igor et grichka en
tout cas voilà ils ont été ils sont
partis voilà mais en tout cas on pensera
toujours à eux bien devant les iem fort
des petits secrets qu'ils avaient faim
moi j'avais toujours remarqué en fait
igor avec toujours une petite oreillette
c'est vrai cooley là je sais pas
pourquoi il a rêvé deux à chaque fois et
puis d'un coup il en avait une victime
dans l'oreillette et abat en fait un
soir j'étais dormir chez lui et avait sa
copine d'ailleurs je me suis réveillé le
matin je lui posais la question parce
que c'est très perturbant il avait tout
le temps quand on lui parle espace est
arrivé très longtemps et je le suis mais
qu'est ce qu'ils écoutent et en fait
c'était
vidéoconférence
tout le temps mais ils étaient capables
d'aller au cinéma de vous tenir une
conversation totalement normal est de
savoir exactement ce qui se passait dans
son oreillette c'était un truc masala
différents moi j'ai juste nourdine